If you had the organs of a serial killer
sewn into you, what would you do?
You now need human flesh to live,
and the government kills people like you.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do and how to beat the terrifying
monsters of Tokyo Ghoul.
This kid is going to get his flesh
ripped from his bones.
Kaneki.
Here is your average kid and manages
to set up a date with the finest girl in town.
This purple haired girl
and Kaneki takes her out on the most amazing date.
And at the end of it,
they pass through this empty alley.
She whispers into his ear
and tells him a naughty secret
when all of a sudden she rips through his flesh
and bites into his neck.
Blood spills everywhere.
As Kaneki looks on in horror and he can do nothing
but realize that this man eater
is about to brutally murder him.
Okay.
I could tell you that going down a dark alley
was a bad idea to begin with on a first date.
But how were we supposed to know
that this seemingly sweet girl
would literally go full octopus mode on us?
Well,
according to Statistic Times dot com, Japan ranks
number 12 on the global peace index scale
behind countries like Switzerland and Iceland,
and is the only Asian country within the top
20 list aside from Singapore.
And if we don't count countries
within the Asia-Pacific region like New Zealand,
but even if we were in Japan,
just avoid dark, scary allies in general.
Guys. Come on, now.
Now, Kaneki running after having his neck
ripped apart, was actually quite reasonable.
As during a traumatic event,
his body would have likely release adrenaline,
triggering his flight or flight response,
and would have caused several self-preservation
responses with one of them being increased energy.
And this means that Kaneki, if he got the chance,
could have run away and have been relatively
fine, sorta even in his condition for hours
after his injuries due to an effect
known as stress induced analgesia,
which is a natural mechanism that comes with the
release of adrenaline that can help people carry
on functioning even after such a traumatic event.
Though, let's be honest,
there's no way we're surviving this.
The best you could have done
was to try and run away and yell for help.
This is why you should never just date
after just looking at a person
a few times during the week,
you should vet them a little bit.
And if you get lonely, that's what long distance
relationships are for.
Kaneki tries to escape, but is grabbed
and toyed around with by purple hair girl.
Her back busts open, revealing blood,
red tentacles, and she tears into his stomach
right in front of him.
She then grabs Kaneki's soft
neck and prepares to bite him for the last time
when suddenly construction pillars
fall down and crush purple hair.
Girl.
Kaneki then suddenly wakes up in a hospital
and he doesn't know how he got here.
This video is sponsored by private internet
access, but oh no, the government's on your ass.
But you got to google how to ask out a chick
before you ask out Touka.
And we're going to eat spicy
ass noodles while we do this.
Private internet
access most transparent VPN provider wants store
any of the weird questions you weebs Google
and I know you Google weird shit I do too.
And they'll keep Japan's government
and the world out of business.
Oh no.
When you're not shooting your shot at Touka
like Wilt Chamberlain at the free throw line,
you can take it easy and watch stuff
like Tokyo Ghoul or even in U.S.
with the click of a button
switching your country to wherever it's available.
But you know all this stuff.
What you don't know
is that these guys have a no logs policy
that's been proven in court multiple times.
They don't keep this stuff
and the courts have actually prove it.
This thing is more customizable
than my spicy noodle dish.
can even add extra chilis in here. It's not spicy.
What am I doing?
We would customize your VPN experience to suit
any and all of yours.
Mine's cheeky browser needs.
Oh, it works with all major streaming
services, blocks, ads is on it is an open
source is available to the public.
Any three countries
with next gen servers up in this bitch
and you can connect up to ten devices.
per subscription, use our link and you will get
an 82% discount on private access.
That's just $2.11 month.
You'll get three months extra completely free,
but get your crypto credit and gift cards out
to support your boys. I'm buying here.
Thank you. To private Internet access
responding to the video. Now back to the show.
He finds out that his organs have been replaced
by uuuhh
donor, the same donor that tore into his flesh
last night.
Purple hair girl.
hungry, He takes a bite out of some food
but realizes it tastes horrible.
He later leaves the hospital to head home
and finds out on the news that there is a ghoul
problem.
In Tokyo, ghouls are vampire
like creatures caused by a virus,
and he finds out that the trait of a ghoul
is that they can't eat any human food.
It tastes horrible to that shocked Kaneki
suddenly runs to his fridge and tries to eat
everything he can get his hands on.
But it all tastes horrible,
causing him to vomit it all back up.
The poor kid starts freaking out
and he realizes that he might just be turning
into a horrifying ghoul himself.
Kaneki hasn't eaten anything in almost 24 hours
and is starving.
He suddenly smells something delicious
and heads outside and runs down this alley
and he follows the smell all the way
to a human corpse that's being eaten by a ghoul.
It offers to share its food with him,
and this horrified Kaneki.
But he doesn't have time
to think as another ghoul shows up and kills
the ghoul that was eating the corpse.
This glasses guy thinks that Kaneki is invading
his killing area and is about to kill him
until the same girl from the cafe
earlier shows up to chase Glass's guy away.
She introduces herself as Touka and tells Kaneki
that he needs to eat human meat to survive.
But Kaneki refuses to admit that he's now a ghoul,
just as an old man
shows up and offers to take him in the old man
takes Kaneki back to his place.
Located right above Kaneki's favorite coffee shop,
he tells Kaneki that he is now part ghoul,
which means he can only eat human flesh
and to drink black coffee.
And he mentions that there is a war coming
and that Kaneki will need to learn how to hunt
if he wants to survive.
He tells him that he'll lose control
if he doesn't feed
and tells him that this coffee shop
is a safe place for ghouls to visit and eat.
The old man thinks that because purple hair girl's
organs are inside Kaneki, he now has her powers.
Okay, at this point, we are on the clock.
If what the old man is telling us is true,
then this means that we don't have long before
we start to lose our minds.
And we already have, to some degree
have experienced a side effects from whatever
this hunger is.
I suck it up and eat whatever
the old man gives me,
because honestly,
we don't have much other choice right now.
But after that I'd begin conducting
my own experiments on myself and see how
we react under stress to our human meat cravings
over this next month.
And I'd also begin to make notes
of how much coffee is needed
to suppress our appetite and for how long
this can be achieved before starvation sets in
because we have a very big problem on our hands
if we're the first human ghoul hybrid,
at least around these parts, then this means
that will begin to draw attention from everyone.
We meet government and ghouls alike, and I'm
willing to bet that unlike the old man here,
there are some sick, twisted sickos out there
who wouldn't mind kidnaping a handsome, healthy
ghoul like me to keep in their basement.
And who knows what they're into?
We need to get a handle on our shit now and learn
everything there is to know about ourselves,
including our abilities, our weaknesses,
and who around here we should and shouldn't
go near the next day, Kaneki goes to school
and struggles to keep it together as he gets
more and more hungry for human flesh
and meets up with his human best friend,
orange haired guy
and Kaneki follows him into a senior student's
office to collect some books and the two bump
into none other than the glasses guy.
But he acts like he's never met
Kaneki before and agrees to help Kaneki's
best friend with some homework at home.
Kaneki stared for his best friend's life, offers
to tag along with the two, the three, then
head out and stop for food and after glasses
guy leads them under this bridge.
Suddenly glasses
guy kicks the shit out of orange hair,
guy down the street, leaving just him and Kaneki
all alone.
Okay.
I don't know who messed up his breakfast,
but glasses guy gets pissed off way too quick.
It seems as though he's a Bikaku ghoul,
which means that he's pretty darn good
at regenerating himself and is durable as hell.
Our best friend we've known
since our childhood is lying there passed out.
Which you know what this means, folks.
We should ditch him right here
and now so we don't get our asses handed to us.
We haven't had any training yet
and we're up against a full on combat ready ghoul.
The only thing that we have on our side
sort of is the illusion of law,
which means I doubt that glasses guy
would like to draw attention to himself
if he can help it.
Our best bet would have been to run like hell
towards
the sunny little street that we just passed
and blend into the sea of people.
And we leave our best friend to die.
This could at least guarantee our safety
while we run back to the coffee shop,
the one that the old man owns,
and whined to him about the school not playing
nice with us because did you see your glasses guy
as scary as face, you got to be sniffing on glue.
If you think I'm fighting that monster glasses
guy gets angry at Kaneki for getting in the way
of his human dinner and attacks him.
He takes a bite out of orange hair guy
and this pisses off Kaneki.
He unleashes a fury filled rage attack and defeats
glasses.
GUY Badly.
But Kaneki then realizes that he now has to face
his most horrifying enemy,
his own hunger for human flesh.
He looks at his best friend, passed out and is
oh so tended to peel the flesh off of his bones
when suddenly Touka shows up to stop him.
She tells him that if he wants to keep
his humanity intact, he needs to learn to resist
the urge to attack his friends and mentions that
no one can know about his ghoul identity ever.
But Kaneki is too hungry
to listen and forces Touka to knock them out.
Later, Kaneki wakes up back at the coffee shop
and realizes that the old man already fed him
the one thing he refused to eat for so long
human flesh.
And this freaks out Kaneki.
But the old man
then offers him a job to work at this coffee shop
and tells him that he'll be able to train here
and learn to live life as a ghoul.
Saying that with some practice, he'll soon
be able to go back to his human life very soon.
Right, Kaneki training and sees humans
and undercover ghouls visit the coffee shop daily.
But then on the news,
they suddenly get word of a series of murders
that have begun to take place in the 20th ward.
Touka hears
this and gets concerned for what's to come.
She then tells Kaneki that if he is to survive,
he must avoid the hunters known as box
carriers, which are police specially trained
in killing and hunting down ghouls.
Okay, if I was Kaneki at this point, I'd study
the old man and find out everything
I could about my situation.
I wouldn't just rely on what he tells me.
I would also become best friends
with the workers of this place
and find out what they know about this place
and how it works.
Because it's unlikely
I'll get the full picture of my situation.
I'm just relying on one source of information.
He may be the one who runs things around here,
but I bet he doesn't have all the answers.
This also leads me to wonder
if this coffee shop is a refuge for ghouls,
why don't they have more like these around
Tokyo's wards?
If I was Kaneki, I talked to the old man
about the possibility of franchising
this establishment by opening up more coffee
shops like this all around Tokyo.
This could benefit us tenfold and would help me
if on the off chance I have to leave the 20th ward
for whatever reason, this would give me a nice
ghouls like me, places to stay.
We can't just sit around and be complacent.
And most importantly,
I got to cover my butt in case
the cops come for me and find me in the 20th ward
in another part of town
at the police headquarters, this guy mentions
that they found a wrench made of Quinque steel
at a recent murder in the 20th ward
and thinks that this wrench
will lead them to the faction behind
all of the deaths happening there.
This is the same ward
where Kaneki was turned into a ghoul,
and the police think that the ghouls
there are up to something horrifying,
but they don't have much time
to get to the bottom of this.
As the police chief mentions
that the 11th Ward of Tokyo
is turning into a war zone between humans
and ghouls, fearing that if they don't solve
all of this soon, a terrifying war will break out
between the species all over Tokyo.
They then send off two of their top dog
detectives, Mr.
Stud over here and Mr. Creepy Face.
And they go investigate the wrench
and the murders down in the 20th ward.
Later at the Ghoul Cafe, old man shows Kaneki
how to pretend to eat like a human and orders
Touka to help Kaneki get a Ghoul Masks.
But he suddenly mentions
that he can sense that two terrifying
ghoul hunters have just entered the 20th ward.
He then tells these two
to step on the gas and Touka and Kaneki rush off
to get him suited up with a mask.
And then they talk about a bunch of useless anime
exposition on the way there and back
the next day, a strange man named Purple
Hair Guy walks into the cafe and suddenly takes
a eerily huge amount of interest in Kaneki.
But Touka warns Kaneki to stay away from him.
But somehow
this guy's charm is too much for Kaneki to handle.
And this guy chats Kaneki up and down and later
even follows him to school
and demands that the two have coffee at his castle
tomorrow night.
And like the gullible little munchkin
that he is, Kaneki agrees.
The next day, Kaneki begins training
with white haired guy and hits up the bar.
Afterwards, there they meet
red haired girl who takes an interest in Kaneki.
He asks her about the identity of his organ
donor, purple haired girl, but she tells him
the only thing anyone knows about her
is that she came from the 11th Ward,
the same ward that is now turned into a war zone.
But red haired girl thinks that purple haired
girl's death was no accident
that someone brutally murdered her.
But of course, she has no proof and makes Kaneki
suspicious as hell.
Later, Kaneki shows up for dinner at purple hair
Guy's Castle, not knowing what horrors await
him, he's greeted with a coffee, but then is
suddenly dumped right into a terrifying death
match arena.
And this huge man shows up
ready to fight Kaneki and brutally tear him apart.
The crowd cheers on as they wait to eat
the losing opponent.
This was purple hair guy's plan all along.
Kaneki tries to escape with his life,
but he gets tossed around more than a chef
with his salad bowl.
And he freaks the hell out
knowing that he's about to die.
Holy balls. Do we have a problem?
This big baby has some big problems,
by the looks of things.
Isn't afraid to toss us around for fun.
But what strikes me about him, and which could
possibly be a weakness of his, is his intellect.
Based on his interaction with that other ghoul
who he calls a mama.
It makes me think that this ghoul
not only has a surprisingly low intellect,
but also relies on people to give him orders
like a baby.
Listening to a parent wonder if we could influence
his mind to deter him from attacking us.
Much like establishing authority towards a child.
I'm wondering
if we could stop him from attacking us
or even make him hand over his weapon to us
through parenting techniques designed to work on
making children abide by rules.
After all, children are much more susceptible
to suggestions from authority figures.
So if we utilized parenting techniques
and negotiation tactics designed to
illustrate are perceived power,
we may be able to gain control over big baby.
If that doesn't work, all we have to do
is to stay outside of the range of his attacks
and let him tire himself out
until he gets exhausted.
Big baby is much bigger than us
and will tire out much faster.
And also because he's so much bigger than us
means that he's going to get hotter, much faster,
and will sweat a whole lot, causing the floor
to get wet and increase the odds of him slipping
and possibly breaking an ankle,
which would increase our odds of survival.
Kaneki knows he's about to be brutally murdered
when suddenly his one eye
turns into the eye of a horrifying ghoul.
This stuns the crowd as they realize
just how rare of a species Kaneki truly is.
Purple haired guy in the distance
sees this and gets a terrifying idea.
He suddenly stops the game and tells Kaneki
that this was all one big joke and lets Kaneki
go free for now.
The next morning,
Kaneki finds out that Touka has gotten sick
from eating too much of her human friend's food.
But she doesn't realize
that her niceness will cost her tonight.
Kaneki then heads out into town
and runs into glasses guy getting beat up.
He saves him and dumps him off at his apartment
where he meets his girlfriend.
And she's human.
This girl says that glasses guy
needs human flesh to heal.
But having none there,
Kaneki runs back to the coffee shop to get some.
And that was his biggest mistake.
He reaches his door when he sees a card
just outside his window with a rose.
It's an invite from purple haired guy
to join him again at church.
But this time he has glasses.
Guy's girlfriend.
Suddenly, like clockwork,
glasses guy shows up, barely clinging to life.
He says that his girlfriend has been taken
and the two ghouls go out to save glasses.
Guy's girlfriend before it's too late.
Okay. This is nuts.
Kidnaping us is one thing, but now it's official.
Purple haired guy is certifiably insane,
which makes him only more dangerous.
We've seen how purple hair guy operates
and how much of a sharp tongue this guy has.
He's a smooth talker.
And this is exactly why I would have waited
and asked more ghouls for help.
So just asking the old man and white haired guy
for their assistance from the letter.
It's not clear what we're up against,
but purple haired guy recently did try to eat me,
so I think it's fair to say that nothing good
is about to happen.
And also, by basically going alone, Kaneki
failed to ensure that his group strength
between him and glasses guy was secure.
Glasses guy is already injured and you already
know, Kaneki barely knows how to do anything.
The only fight they are going to have for them
is their trust between them as teammates,
which is already in jeopardy by purple hair
guy's, charisma.
Hear me out now.
Charismatic individuals often do
well in positions of power, but these attributes
can run the risk of sabotaging relationships
and eroding trust between people and groups.
The problem is, is that purple haired
guy is smart and already in a position of power
and he's holding all of the cards.
Kaneki going alone with the glasses.
Guy means that purple haired guy
through his charisma and position of power,
could convince glasses guy to turn against us.
After all, purple
hair guy does have glasses guy's girlfriend,
which means there's nothing to stop him
from ordering glasses guy to follow his orders.
And we know glasses.
Guy will do anything to save his girlfriend.
Kaneki should have gotten help from people
with no invested interest in the situation.
So does the old man, white haired guy,
or possibly even Touka at the church.
The boys find glasses, guy's girlfriend, horribly
bound and blinded by ropes, and she lays on
top of a table
ready to be eaten like a holiday ham.
Purple hair guy is a total foodie and demands
that Kaneki feast on glasses guy's girlfriend
as purple hair guy feasts on Kaneki but that's
when Kaneki sees the scars on this girl.
He realizes that glasses guy
has been feeding on his girlfriend.
Kaneki then gets angry
and he and Touka attack purple haired guy.
But they both realize that none of them have it in
flesh and a while
and are no match for this bad guy.
So Kaneki lets Touka take a bite out of his body
and they then badly injure purple haired guy.
Good. Okay.
Touka showing up was a welcome surprise,
but she played it risky.
She shouldn't have been eating any human food
at all, even from her friends.
And they almost got herself killed in the process.
This is why you should never try to be too good
of a friend.
Always settle for mediocrity, people.
Now, the good news is that purple haired
guy wanted
Kaneki as part of his plan
and likely wouldn't have minded
waiting a little bit longer
before harming glasses.
Guy's girlfriend, so long as he thought
that Kaneki would take part in his plan.
This is why I'm suggesting bringing more people
to take on purple hair guy as it's obvious
he's a strong ghoul and is likely capable
of taking on a lot of damage.
Regular old ghouls
can take serious damage with a strong injury
to the stomach or by decapitation to the head
and are also a little bit stronger
depending on if they just ate.
But I'm guessing our purple haired
foodie over here is always feasting on flesh,
which means his Kagune powers are likely
at their strongest or near their strongest.
I would have utilized Touka and a third party
by making them hide
outside the church and lure a purple haired
guy out towards there with Kaneki.
Then after I would have tried going for his head
while glasses Guy sneaks in the back of the church
to rescue his girlfriend,
then combating purple haired guy.
If decapitation didn't work, I would have tried
enabling him to use up all of his powers on me
in succession, as that is a method to weaken
ghouls is to have them use up their power cells
through constant attacks or deployed Kagunes.
And with enough time in the ring,
I think we could have weakened
purple haired guy enough to either
critically wound him or scare him off entirely.
Purple hair guy is on the brink of death,
and that's when Touka calms down
and she realizes that Glasses Guy's
girlfriend knows the identity of ghouls.
Therefore, she has to die.
Glasses guy desperately begs
for his girlfriend's life, but Touka doesn't
listen as she prepares to end this girl's life.
But suddenly the girlfriend comments
on how beautiful Touka looks, which set into this
ghoul and Touka caves at the last minute, sparing
this girl's life, and she runs away days later.
Glasses guy ends up working at the Ghoul
coffee shop and everything seems to be hunky dory.
But none of these people realize
that their life is about to change for the worse.
Suddenly, this ghoul mother walks into the cafe,
not realizing that she's about to die.
In less than an hour, Kaneki notices
this concerned customer and checks in with her,
and she tells Kaneki about her family drama.
Oh, boo hoo.
Her husband is in some debt with some bad guys,
and he's been trying to pay it off.
Her husband is a blacksmith and he is used by bad
ghouls to make weapons and tools for them.
We see him hard at work at his office
as this guy shows up called White Suit. Man.
This man tells the husband
that the police are looking for
the wrench that he made in connection
with a recent murder in the 20th ward
and that he'd better keep his mouth shut
if he wants to live
and throws them outside the window to punish him.
And that's when his worst nightmare shows up.
It's the box carriers,
Mister Stud and creepy face white suit man escapes
just as these police
tell the husband that they think
he's behind the murders in the 20th ward
since they know he made the wrench.
The husband tries to fight back like an idiot
and get slaughtered, and he falls to the floor,
holding a drawing that his daughter made for him.
And unfortunately for him,
he doesn't realize that this exact drawing
will cost him
the life of his wife in less than an hour.
Okay, Pops, over here was one stupid fellow
to try and go up against a professionally trained
ghoul investigator.
These guys are the best of the best and know
how to handle ghouls without much problem.
And also, like I said about Kaneki,
if I was a ghoul, I'd study religiously.
Everything there is to know about the CCG police,
and I'd especially study the ways and methods
and abilities and tactics of my kind's
worst enemy, the ghoul investigator himself,
and whoever their top members are.
This way we could have at least known better
as to what we were up against.
Creepy face over here is the best of the best
and the most ruthless of them all.
And his handling of his weapons
means that Pops was no match for him.
In this case, we had little choice, but to run
and hopefully take refuge somewhere safer before
figuring out our next step.
Or we could have run
just far enough before taking a human hostage
and use them as a distraction before escaping.
Likely we couldn't have done much,
but fighting was definitely not the first option
I would have gone with after everybody
gets all caffeinated up at the Ghoul Cafe.
The mother and daughter head back home,
but that's when the daughter realizes
that something is not right.
She smells something and follows
the scent down the street.
It's her dad's scent
and the two follow it down this alley.
And that's when a wave of dread hits
the mother's face. She sees Mr.
Stud and Creepy face standing across from them,
holding the body parts of this woman's husband.
The mother quickly
unleashes her full ghoul powers,
and she tells her daughter one simple word run,
and she sprints away and runs into Kaneki,
and he is forced to hold back
this little girl's pain and trauma,
as they're both forced to watch this mother
get brutally murdered right here and now.
Later, the ghoul gang mourns
the death of the mother, and Touka gets so mad
that she leaves the cafe.
She's determined to slaughter the police
and make them pay.
And she heads to a ramen shop nearby
that's beloved by the police.
There she sees Mr.
Stud and some of his coworkers, and she brutally
murders this policeman and tries to take Mr.
Stud on herself.
He tries to defend himself, but that's when Mr.
Creepy face shows up
and he knows everything about ghouls.
Touka tries to kill this guy, but he's too good
for her own good and forces her to run away.
But her ghoul bunny mask is one thing Mr.
Creepy Face can't get out of his mind.
And now he'll come for her very soon.
Okay.
I would love to talk to Touka right now
and ask her
why are you so dang distracted
and in your own head
that you feel to be in the present
and act in a more calculated manner?
Going in unprepared
and attacking head on is a bad idea.
She was outmatched in both numbers
and physical strength.
Touka should have realized her strengths better
and played to them rather than out of emotion.
Touka herself is a type of ghoul that specializes
in high speed attacks, which means
that her enhanced speed and mobility is her main
bread and butter and not brute strength.
If I was there and helping Touka
because I do like the idea of killing ghoul
investigators,
I would suggest we go to their home of residence
and kill them
when they're at their most vulnerable.
Touka could have followed the investigators back
to their separate homes and killed them one by one
over the course of a few nights.
Granted, each night
that passes would have gotten progressively harder
as the news of a cop
killer would no doubt put everyone more on edge.
However, she also could have avoided this
by concentrating her
efforts on the main a ghoul investigator
that actually killed the girl's mom.
Creepy face revenge doesn't solve anything
unless you do it right.
The days pass as this girl mourns
the death of her parents.
She finally decides to get away
from the Ghoul Cafe to get some air.
And then she smells something.
It's the scent of her mother.
She runs like mad to track down her mother's scent
and heads down into this sinister tunnel.
But suddenly creepy face shows up,
squeals and screams echo throughout the streets
until Kaneki's hears her.
He desperately runs to find her,
but then runs into Mr.
Stud, and Kaneki is pissed as hell and turns
into a full monster and manages to destroy Mr.
Studs Quinque.
But this ghoul killer isn't no crybaby and tells
Kaneki to finish the damn job and kill him.
But Kaneki hasn't eaten in forever and he begs Mr.
Stud to run for his life
before he becomes Kaneki's lunch.
Finally, Mr.
Stud listens to Kaneki and runs off,
and Kaneki goes to find the little girl back
under the bridge.
Touka finally reaches
the little girl, screams and attacks creepy face
until he reveals something horrifying.
Creepy faces weapon is made from the flesh
of this little girl's mother.
Terrifying this girl.
And this finally makes Touka lose it.
She beats the shit out of creepy face and chops
off his hand, leaving him on the brink of death.
And then Kaneki and White haired guys
show up to take the little girl and Touka away.
Okay.
This could have been easily avoided
if they just knew how to contain the little brat.
They should not have put someone there
to just watch her.
They should also installed
some sort of a tracker on her.
It's obvious that after her mother's death,
the little girl would have likely been
altered psychologically, at least to some degree.
This is common
with individuals who experience severe trauma,
like witnessing the death of a loved one.
And this can cause temporary
or even permanent personality alteration
and lead to a dramatic shift in behavior
from general temperament to general stress,
tolerance, and even an altered outlook on life.
We don't know how much this affected
this little girl,
but it's safe to say
that at this current period of time,
the little girl is a liability and a problem
if she handles this poorly.
And the other man should have had better
security measures during this period of time.
Also being such a feared member of the ghoul
investigators, it wouldn't be improbable to say
that Touka, along with the rest of the ghouls,
could have figured out a way
in advance the limitation of creepy faces.
Quinque as Creepy
Phase has a habit of collecting Quinques
and since his tend to be made from the past
ghouls he's killed.
They could have used this information
to figure out creepy faces, weak points
when using each of his selected weapons.
Again, this should have been done way in advance.
Touka would have had much better luck in
changing her tactics from offensive to defensive.
Creepy faces. Second, Quinque was made
from the little girl's mother's kagune.
And hers is a type of Quinque
that is extremely durable
and can function as both offense and defense.
However, this guy's weapon, because of its
ginormous size, means that they would have had
a hard time being as mobile in tight areas,
and Touka could have used this to her advantage.
The next day, Kaneki goes to Redhead Girl's Bar
to find out more information about Purple haired
girl and finds out
that she came from the 11th Ward of Tokyo.
Redhead tells Kaneki
that he'll probably get some answers on her
if he goes to the 11th Ward himself.
But she warns him that he needs to go soon
as police forces will soon arrive there to cause
some trouble.
Nearby, a group of horrifying ghouls
show up to the 20th ward, and they prepare for
their mission to find purple haired girl
before anyone else does,
starting at her favorite coffee shop,
the one Kaneki works at.
Later at police headquarters, Mr.
Stud is give it a new band of assistance
as everyone prepares for their horrifying mission
to invade the 11th Ward.
And they suddenly get a call
from the 11th Ward itself.
They find out that terrifying ghouls
have taken over all the police stations there,
killing every single cop they could find,
and they watch everyone on the screen
get brutally killed.
Back at the coffee shop, a ghoul named Mr.
Goatee shows up with his henchmen
and asks about the location of purple haired girl.
But he suddenly catches her
scent on Kaneki and demands.
He tells him where she is
but Kaneki knocks this guy to the floor.
But Kaneki doesn't want to hurt
this guy's feelings, so he lies and tells Mr.
Goatee that purple haired
girl left the cafe earlier today.
Mr. Goatee thinks purple hair
girl is alive and cheers up and he then throws
Kaneki a bone and tells him
that trouble is looking for him as they speak.
Some more ghouls, a cipher.
Mr. Goatee have recently invaded the 20th ward
looking for purple hair girl too.
But these ghouls are crazy as hell.
And just like the 11th Ward's plan
to turn this place into a war zone, too.
Mr. Goatee, thanks Kaneki
for his time at his squad, heads out.
Suddenly Mr.
Goatee comes flying back in through the shop
window glass
and then steps the psycho mob boss from before Mr.
White suit.
He takes an immediate interest in Kaneki
and asks him for purple hair girl's location.
But Kaneki doesn't tell him shit,
so he beats the crap out of him as everybody
nearby looks around helpless.
These guys are true killers
and have horrifying plans for Kaneki.
Touka tries to stop this thug from kidnaping him,
but purple hair Kid brutally beats her
before they leave and also reveals to everyone
that he is her long lost brother. Yay.
Family reunited later.
The old man and white haired guy come back to the
now utterly destroyed coffee shop and find out
that Kaneki has been kidnaped.
But the old man is one stubborn bastard
and gathers the rest of his crew to go save
Kaneki, calling everyone
he knows like red girl and even purple haired guy.
And he knows that so many lives are going to die.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
While I admire the strong ties
old man has to his people, realistically,
there's little chance in hell
that we'll be able to save Kaneki
without losing a lot of our people in the process.
We're about to storm the 11th Ward.
Imagine the apartment building from the movie
DREDD. That's how bad it is over there.
There's a reason why thousands of people have died
so far in the 11th Ward.
Wow. Admirable. This plan is completely stupid.
Even if you bring the silver tongued weirdo purple
hair guy, we're going up against an army
and we have less than two bakers, dozens
worth of ghouls on our side for good measure,
I would have at least try to hire other ghouls
for insurance to help us in our upcoming battle.
We may not get their loyalty,
but at least they'll make for a better distraction
if we bring more bodies
to this upcoming bloodbath.
If anything, we could have used more hired
ghouls as a distraction tactic using them.
And the cops who we know are headed there
to keep the majority of the 11th Ward busy
while we look for Kaneki.
Kaneki, he wakes up and realizes
that he's in the horrifying 11th Ward
and white sewage man begins to interrogate Kaneki
in the most terrifyingly delicious ways
possible, like removing each of these ghouls
fingers and toes again and again.
As they do regenerate,
they quickly drive Kaneki insane
and he finally loses his shit and breaks free
and savagely kills Mr.
Suit Guy as his hair turns a soulless white,
turning him into a full on powerful ghoul.
And this now monster consumes dooms
this guy whole.
Meanwhile, just outside, the old man and his gang
prepare to invade the 11th ward
along with thousands of police nearby.
The police storm in and hundreds of ghouls
and police die instantly.
It's a horrifying battle
and blood is spilled everywhere.
But something is not right
as everyone here realizes it.
They soon hear the rumbling of something
terrifying in the distance.
This police general's face goes pale
as he sees what everyone else does.
The most powerful, evil ghoul
in the history of mankind.
The old man can sense
what horrors are about to happen.
And this guy tells his task force that anyone
who doesn't want to die should leave now.
And just this small group readies their weapons
and prepare to fight the bloodiest battle
against the most powerful bad guy in the world.
The one eyed owl.